[موسيقى]
قد يكون انهيار كولورادو بطلاً ،
لكن كأس ستانلي في كأس ستانلي انتهى به الأمر
إلى تلقي التحية من قبل كلب نباح تم
تسليمه إلى العنوان الخطأ عندما
فتحه ، كنت مثل
زوجي كاربلر وديمتري رودنكو المتزوجين منذ فترة طويلة
لم يتوقعوا أي
توصيلات  سيارة الدفع الرباعي مدعومة في
دربهم في اليوم الآخر
وتجسس ديميتري على قضية بدت
مألوفة لذلك قال مازحا
إنها كأس ستانلي ويقول نعم
إنه أحد رجلي التوصيل اللذين قلت
جيدًا هل يمكنني رؤيته هل يمكنني لمسها
وهو  بالتأكيد ، كان أول شيء فعلته
هو الشعور بالحافة التي كان من المفترض أن تذهب بها الكأس
إلى قائد الفريق ،
لكن عنوان منزله كان رقمًا واحدًا فقط
بعيدًا عن هريرة ديميتري ، هل أنت من
عشاق لعبة الهوكي ، نحن الآن من عشاق لعبة الهوكي ، نحن الآن من عشاق لعبة الهوكي.
لم يكن لدى الطفل الخارجي الوقت لالتقاط هذه الصورة
إلا إذا كان لديه وقت أطول فقط ، كان بإمكاني
تناول مشروب الكلب منه ، وكان اللاعبون
يقبلون الكأس ويتفاخرون بها ، لكن مجموعته
لوحت على الفور في نص
لمسها بعلامة تعجب  Nds
مثل إحدى تلك النكات القديمة
التي تعمل بالقرص المطرق ، تدق من هناك
ستانلي
ستانلي الذي
يشرط
الشرطي يركض على العثور على
كأس ستانلي على بابهم ،
هذا هو المارد المجنون
cnn نيويورك